- And so now we are pleased
to invite to the podium
Dr. Bennett Leventhal who's
professor of psychiatry
and training director in child
and adolescent psychiatry
and Deputy Directory of the
UCSF STAR Program for Autism
Spectrum Disorders and
Neurodevelopmental Disorders
at Langley Porter.
He is an active investigator
and practicing clinician.
His research includes
studies of the epidemiology
and causes of autism
spectrum disorders as well as
other neurodevelopmental disorders.
And he's involved with a
number of clinical trials
to improve outcomes in these conditions.
Dr. Leventhal.
(applause)
Thank you.
- Hi there, it's Friday afternoon.
I'll go fast, okay?
Let's see if I can get
the slides to go forward.
Okay, these are my disclosures.
I've done a couple clinical
trials, but none of them
are relevant directly to this.
Okay.
So, I'm gonna talk about
Autism Spectrum Disorder
but in many ways there
are things about ASD that
really reflect broadly into
other neurodevelopmental
disorders, and I hope by
the end you'll understand
that many of the treatments
are not terribly specific
and that this is really
a broad group of patients
that have a whole variety
of overlapping symptoms.
So what's a neurodevelopmental disorder?
Well, it's something
that's usually syndromal.
Now syndromal is slightly
different from what
Dr. Sher talked about.
It means that it's a--I'll
explain in a minute--
but it's a group of symptoms
that I'll talk about.
Almost all these disorders
begin in childhood,
and usually early
childhood if not in utero.
They all affect brain functioning
in some way or another
and they have clinical effects
on emotions, cognitions,
and behavior.
By DSM5, this is the list of
neurodevelopmental disorders,
and it's a long list.
The ones we're gonna
primarily talk about now
are Autism Spectrum Disorder
and a related condition
called Social Communication Disorder.
That is it's basically ASD
but without the restrictive
repetitive and stereotype behaviors.
But in some sense, many
of these conditions
can have some of the symptoms
that we're interested in.
And by the way, even
though DSM reflects that
as the list of
neurodevelopmental disorders,
I would advise you to
think broadly because
I think there are very many
other conditions that have
early onset that follow
a disrupted development
and actually have symptoms
that also overlap.
And some of you might be
surprised to see Alzheimer's
on that list, but in fact,
there's gonna be, I think,
growing evidence that
you'll be able to detect
some of the pathology
of Alzheimer's disease
in genetically vulnerable
individuals very early in life.
So what is autism?
It's a syndrome.
A syndrome is a group
of symptoms that tend
to cluster together.
It doesn't say that
everybody has all of them.
And they tend to cluster
together in shared
common natural history.
That is, they get better
or worse over time.
A disease is a syndrome for
which there's a known cause
or for which there's a known
pathophysiologic process
or both.
Most of the things that we talk about,
even if we know the
gene, we don't actually
often know the pathophysiology, that is
actually what's happened,
what's disrupted in the brain
to cause the kind of symptoms we have.
So most of the things we talk
about in neurodevelopmental
terms in developmental
disabilities are syndromes.
And we don't really know the cause.
That doesn't mean we can't do anything.
And by the way, most medical
conditions are syndromes.
Diabetes, cardiovascular disease, asthma.
We can go down the list.
Most of them are syndromes.
And we don't really know
what the causes are,
but we actually have treatments.
Now most people when they think about
Autism Spectrum Disorder they think about
what's in the lay media or in movies.
And in some cases, they're
quite good depictions
and in some cases they aren't.
But what's good to remember is
how diverse these people are.
That they're very
different characterizations
of the same syndrome however artistically
they might be portrayed.
Of course, I think one
of the best depictions is
of a high-functioning
individual is "Temple Grandin"
with Claire Danes.
Even Temple Grandin
thought it was pretty good.
(laughter)
So the term autism came
from a man by the name
of Leo Kanner who in
1943 wrote a paper called
"Autistic Disturbances
of Affective Contact"
in a journal called The Nervous Child.
We no longer have the
journal, but we still have
nervous children and parents.
And they're concerned about these kids.
But in fact, autism didn't begin in 1943.
It's been around for as long
as there's been human beings.
A very famous case is
the wild boy of Aveyron,
a boy who was found
wandering around in the town
of Averyron in the late 1700s
and was picked up by Itard.
Itard is on the left and
Victor's on the right.
And Itard took Victor to
Paris and tried to train him,
and Victor learned many things, how to sit
at a dinner table, how to
dress, but he never learned
to speak and all of his
social skills were quite rote.
But there are many other
case reports like this.
Now it also reflects in some
sense the kind of concerns
people had about causes.
They thought Victor was
raised by wolves in the forest
and that's why he wasn't
properly civilized.
In point of fact, Victor
was probably developmentally
disabled and in those days
you could kill your children.
It was perfectly permissible.
It wasn't illegal because children were
thought of as property.
And this was a very kind family.
Instead of killing their child,
they just turned him loose
in the forest, and he
came out the other side
and got found by Itard and
moved to Paris and lived
a better life than his
parents probably did.
Just goes to show, there is some justice.
Lucky he wasn't an immigrant.
(laughter)
So these are DSM5 criteria for ASD.
You'll see that they
are two main criteria,
deficits and social
communication, social interaction
and B, the restricted,
repetitive patterns of behavior,
interests, and activities.
And these are the basic
diagnostic tools that we use,
but as you can see there are
a large group of symptoms
and how one aggregates them
and the extent to which
they impair somebody is highly variable.
By the way, this is Social
Communication Disorder,
and you can see it's
very similar but it says
that the social communication
abilities are disrupted
because of language
function, and it doesn't have
the--it doesn't have the
restricted repetitive behaviors.
I think the story about
this remains to be told.
I'm not sure that we really
know how different it is.
And it may be a distinction
without a difference
in the long term, but we'll find out.
Now when it comes to thinking about
Autism Spectrum Disorders
I actually just include
Social Communication
Disorder when we think
about its treatment.
So it's a syndrome.
It characterized by developmental delays
and developmental deviations.
That is things occur that don't occur
in typical development.
The domains of impairment
are largely in the areas
of social development, as we've discussed,
with disruptions in joint
attention, theory of mind,
and difficulties with reciprocity.
Joint attention is the
ability to join other people
in what they're paying attention to
and theory of mind is to have
a notion that someone else
has thoughts just like you do and that you
have to be able to respond to those.
They're communication problems,
as has been mentioned,
and then this set of unusual behaviors.
The course is consistent over time.
That is most people with
ASD get better over time
with a few exceptions, Rett Syndrome
being one of them and some
of the other syndromes
that Dr. Sher talked about where there's
continuing damage to the brain.
But most of the people we
know get better over time.
Some of the symptoms seem
to diminish over time,
particularly the repetitive
behaviors and the problems
with looking people--having visual regard.
Other symptoms persist
and don't seem to go away.
Problems with social
reciprocity, language,
and the restricted repetitive
behaviors of certain types
such as persistent interest
in things or difficulty
making changes, insistence on sameness.
By the way, if we know some
of them change over time,
it's gonna actually have an
implication for treatment.
And we'll get to that in a minute.
So what of the--if it's a
spectrum, Autism Spectrum Disorder
what constitutes the spectrum?
Well, the symptoms themselves,
these little unusual
autism behaviors, insistence
on sameness, rocking,
things of that sort, and
then--but also language skills,
the ability to communicate,
language being broadly
not just speech but the full spectrum of
communicative behaviors.
The severity of social skills
and then intellectual ability.
So in a sense, if you're
on the far left hand--
let's see--left hand side of
this picture, and you have
mild in all those areas,
you're gonna appear to be
higher functioning, so-called,
and if you have more
severe impairment, you're
gonna end up on the other
side of the spectrum.
And it'll vary because the
symptom picture varies.
Remember it's a syndrome,
so not everybody has
all the same symptoms or
symptoms of the same severity.
So what causes it?
Well, you've heard
about--Dr. Sher talked about
genes or chromosomal
syndromes and other kinds of
genetics that suggest that
there's an increased risk
if you have a sibling or
a family member with ASD,
but there are other things
that can cause ASD as well
as Dr. Sher has shown you.
I think one of the critical
things that we need to remember
is that there probably
isn't a single cause,
there are probably many, and they're not
a single genetic cause.
And genes interact with the
environment and so to say
there's an environmental
or is it biological,
the answer is yes.
And thinking about it dichotomously
is not really helpful.
That's not to say that bad
mothers, as an environmental
factor, cause autism.
They do not.
They can not.
As powerful as mothers are,
they can't cause autism.
They can cause lots of other
aggravation, but not...
(laughter)
But I would point out, dads
can too, and aunts and uncles
and grandmas and everybody.
We can all impact children.
But what is important to
remember is even if it's
a basic biological disorder,
which I think most of us
believe, experience in life
around you as you develop,
the quality of education,
the quality of services,
the quality of parenting,
the quality of nutrition,
the quality of healthcare,
all those things impact all
of our development including
children with autism.
They're not immune.
And they may be even more
vulnerable to some of those
environmental factors.
So what about treatment,
which is what I'm really
supposed to be talking about.
Well, treatment begins with, first of all,
understanding that we're
dealing with a group
of symptoms not necessarily
a specific disease
for which we know a cause.
We're not treating a cause.
And you have to start by
carefully assessing the patients.
It's what Dr. Sher talked about earlier
and we're gonna reiterate.
You really have to do
a careful assessment.
And what constitutes a careful assessment?
You have to screen for a
broad variety of potential
causes or problems, ranging from genetic
to environmental factors.
You have to interview the patient.
You have to talk to them.
I know, you say well, kids
with autism don't always talk.
First of all, the vast
majority of them talk.
They may not talk in ways that's
the easiest to understand,
but they can communicate
and spending time with them is important.
Of course, taking histories
from family members,
and you actually have to
see the kid and see them
interact in the environment around them.
There are a whole variety
of standard diagnostic
instruments which have
been well established,
are empirically valid which
should always be used,
but just because you
can get an ADI, Autism
Diagnostic Interview, or
ADOS, Autism Diagnostic
Observation Schedule,
be positive it still is
a clinical diagnosis.
So just because you get a
test score that's positive
doesn't mean that they
have or if it's negative
that they don't have the disorder.
It's information that helps you.
And then you have to look
at adaptive functioning.
So it's not just that you have a disorder
but how it impairs it your
life and how it impairs
your living because in fact
the kind of treatments we do
are designed to improve the
quality of life and the skills
of the individual, not
just take away the symptoms
that make a diagnosis.
And Dr. Sher made a
cogent point about doing
a careful examination.
These kids are not always easy to do
physical examinations on and as a result
many physicians,
pediatricians in particular,
will just brush through the exam.
And these kids, more than anybody else,
deserve a thorough exam.
I can't tell you, and
I'm guessing that Elliot
will do the same thing,
and tell you how many kids,
young kids I've seen who
had sensory impairment
who looked like they had autism.
They couldn't hear or they couldn't see.
And when you carefully
examine them, you find out
that they can't--and you help them see
and you help them hear, they
do a lot better socially.
Although sometimes if I don't
hear I do better socially, too
but that's another story altogether.
And then of course there
are laboratory tests
that Dr. Sher's talked about.
Now one of the factors
that predict outcomes
for kids, with people with autism--
why do I want to know this?
Because if I can change
them, then it'll improve
their outcomes, so
expressive language by having
communicative speech by the age of 5
and understanding spoken
language by the age of 5
seems to have pretty
good prognostic features.
That would make you think right away,
speech and language services would be
really important, right?
Intellectual capacity.
Not a lot we can do to
change intellectual capacity.
Adaptive function, teaching kids skills.
And then the severity
of autism symptoms, like
social deficits, restricted,
repetitive behaviors,
and aggression.
Notice they're way down
at the bottom there.
Sadly those are the
ones--I'm going to talk
about medications--are the
ones we can deal with most.
And what I'm telling you
is that the most important
interventions really are
not things that we use
medications for.
So these are the kind of
interventions that you
should be using and
pharmacotherapy is just one
and at the bottom of the list.
Okay.
So which behaviors can we deal with?
We have to take the
symptoms out of the syndrome
and say which of the
symptoms from the syndrome
can we address?
So let's--the first one that seems to be
very disruptive and interferes
with children's lives
are the restricted and
repetitive behaviors.
Now let me just talk
about those for a moment.
You know them very well,
but it includes getting
fixated on a particular object or watching
Finding Nemo over and over and over again
or worse than that a two
minute interval of Finding Nemo
over and over and over again.
And when you make the
child stop doing that,
they get really upset and can tantrum.
Now there are a number
of problems with that
particular kind of behavior.
There's nothing wrong with Nemo.
I mean, Nemo's an okay guy.
But the problem is if that's all you do,
then you can't learn other stuff.
And you can't engage socially
in the rest of the world
around you and if anybody
tries to change it
then you get all bent out of shape,
that makes it difficult for people to then
move you on to other things.
This whole principle of
insistence on sameness,
the difficulty in making changes,
changing the environment,
if you move a piece of furniture
or something in the house
and the child gets upset,
or if they have to change
from reading class to mathematics class
and they fall apart, it
makes it very difficult
to provide education for them.
And the world in which we
live isn't fixed and stable.
So learning how to participate
in the broader world
around you so that you can
go to school and go to church
or go to Boy Scouts or
Girl Scouts or play sports,
in order to do those
things, you have to have
some flexibility.
So this is one of the
behaviors that we think
we can make some headway
with by using medications.
I'm gonna at the end
caution you about all this,
but in the beginning we'll talk about.
So the medications that seem
to be the most effective
in doing this at the
moment are the Selective
Serotonin Reuptake Inhibitors, or SSRIs.
And this is a list of all
of them, Prozac and Zoloft
are probably the best known.
But the--and how did we
figure out to do this?
Well, we actually didn't
figure it out in autism.
It turned out there were a bunch of dogs
that had repetitive behaviors,
something they called
acral lick syndrome, where
they lick the perianal glands
and they would do it so
badly that they would
get themselves infected
and actually could die.
And someone figured out
that if you gave them a drug
called a Anafranil or clomipramine,
the one on the bottom,
they would stop doing
this repetitive behavior.
So then people tried to
use it in humans who had
compulsive disorders,
obsessive compulsive disorder,
and it worked to a moderate
degree, and then finally
it got used in autism.
But for other kids,
including children with
intellectual disability who
have these kinds of behaviors.
And it had a moderate amount of success.
This is one of the
earlier papers looking at
children with autism using a measure
obsessive compulsive
behaviors and you can see that
the kids with--
the placebo's on the top and
with ASD got substantially
better in a relatively
short period of time.
And when you looked at
their overall outcome,
just their global improvement
in taking every aspect
of their behavior, there
was a really statistically
significant difference
between the kids who were
on placebo and the kids
who were on, in this case,
fluoxetine or Prozac.
So it looks like this makes a difference.
It doesn't work for
everybody, and in some cases
it may make them worse
for a variety of reasons,
but it looks like it
has a powerful effect.
And when you look at side
effects, which I think
we always have to do,
and I love this table
because this is a table
where almost every one
of the side effects is
worse on the placebo.
(laughter)
Well, that's an important
thing to remember,
that sometimes people
perceive things that may not
necessarily--that was a good idea.
So sometimes people
perceive things that may not
actually be relevant to or
causal by the medication.
So it's really important when
we work with our patients
to help them understand
what the side effects can be
but also monitor them.
Next group of symptoms
that are really problematic
with children with ASD is
aggression and irritability.
So in the past going back
50 years, 50 years now,
the use of drugs called
neuroleptics, Thorazine,
was one of them, or
Haldol, have been shown
repeatedly in a variety
of settings irrespective
of the diagnosis that
you can reduce aggression
in individuals and
irritability in individuals
by giving them these drugs.
These drugs had many awful
side effects and many
patients won't take
them and so there's now
a new group of drugs called
atypical neuroleptics
or second generation neuroleptics
and two of these drugs,
risperidone or Risperdal
and aripiprazole or Abilify
have been approved by the FDA on the basis
of clinical trials to
treat the irritability
associated with autism.
Now I want to be clear.
It's not to treat autism.
It's to treat irritability
associated with autism,
the kind of irritability
we talked about in response
to the stereotyped behaviors.
Now this was a study done
by an NIH sponsored grant,
and you can see that the kids,
the green line are the kids
on risperidone and the kids
on placebo are the gray line,
and in as quickly as two
weeks, there was significant
separation between the
kids who were being treated
and the kids who were not.
And this treatment and
the effect persisted
and continued to get better
over an eight-week period.
And it looks like it stays
sustained in longer studies
after that.
About 75% of the kids on
risperidone got much improved
to very much improved
whereas only 11% if the kids
on placebo.
So it's about--I mean it
makes a really big difference
in these kids.
But not every behavior gets better.
And this is important.
So hyperactivity got better.
Restricted and repetitive
behaviors got better.
Aggression got better.
But the social functioning didn't change.
And inappropriate speech didn't change.
It was not statistically different.
So it doesn't treat the whole syndrome,
and even by treating part of the syndrome
doesn't mean that everything
else will get better.
However, if a child's less
irritable and less aggressive,
they're probably more
amenable to engage in speech
and language therapy,
behavior therapy, et cetera.
And so using this to supplement
those, or to augment them,
is really the way to think
about it, not how to cure
the disorder or make all
the symptoms of the syndrome
go away.
This is a slightly different
view of side effects,
just again to give you a
perspective, and the side effect
that you really want to pay
most attention to on almost
all the side effects here
are higher on risperidone
and the one that I think you
need to pay most attention to
is the one at the very bottom.
In an eight-week trial,
the average of 49 kids,
the average child gained
2.7 kilos, which is
about six pounds versus .8
kilos in the control group.
So you really have to
watch this and manage it
because weight gain is a serious problem.
But there are other symptoms as well.
Okay.
Now there are a number of other
drugs that have been around
for a very long time that
have been shown to decrease
aggressive behavior again
irrespective of diagnosis.
One is lithium carbonate
and is a drug we use
for bipolar disorder but
is extremely effective
actually across the board.
So when we have kids that don't respond to
the neuroleptics, it's
harder to manage this drug
because you have to use blood
levels and you have to be
careful to keep the kids well-hydrated.
But in general it's
extremely effective and has
relatively fewer side effects
because it's only the lithium
that doesn't metabolize
into anything else.
And then there's a drug called
propranolol which has been
shown to decrease aggressive
behavior in a whole variety
of individuals including those
with neurodevelopmental disorders.
It's the drug Inderal.
It's an anti-hypertensive.
But unfortunately, you have to
give it in very large doses.
Something around 400
to 800 milligrams a day
which you--it may make some people,
their blood pressure drop,
although I've had kids
on 800 milligrams a
day and they don't have
any blood pressure changes at all.
So I don't--go figure that out.
But again, it's another option for us.
And aggression is the
biggest problem when we have
presenting patients, and so
trying to find a solution
is important.
What about attention deficit disorder?
First of all, it used to be
said that you couldn't have
ADHD and ASD.
Now you can.
Someone voted and said
it's true, but those of us
who are clinicians have known it all along
and so we--many kids with ASD have ADHD.
And so we treat with
the standard stimulants
that you're familiar with.
There are dozens of them now.
And there are now studies
in children with ASD
who treating their ADHD
symptom, and this is
a this is a crossover
trial and it just shows
that whether you got it--
that parents, teachers, both
see the kids get better,
and significantly better in
terms of paying attention.
So it used to be said
stimulants didn't work with kids
with ASD.
That's completely not true.
It doesn't work for
everybody, but it doesn't
work for every kid with ADHD either.
So using stimulants with kids
who have attention problems
is quite effective.
For those kids who can't
tolerate stimulants,
there are some other
non-stimulant medications
and in particular Strattera
or atomoxetine and then
the alpha-adrenergic agonists
clonidine and guanfacine.
There's some recent studies
that show that they're
moderately effective.
I don't think that they're
nearly as effective
as the stimulants.
I would only use them
either as an augmentation
or as a--we'll do
questions at the end, okay?
As a supplement, not
as a primary treatment.
Some may disagree with me.
Then mood disturbance.
Children get, with ASD, get depressed.
A, what's the surprise about that?
Autism doesn't protect
you from depression.
And in fact, it may make
you more vulnerable.
And if you're higher
functioning, it may be
a real struggle for you.
And so there's no reason
to think that treating kids
with mood disorders with
ASD with the usual suspects
of the Serotonin Reuptake
Inhibitors is the best option
for these kids.
And then finally, and then
in some cases people use
mood stabilizers like the anticonvulsants.
This is actually quite
convenient, particularly
for those kids who have seizure disorders,
you can get double dipping
with both of these agents.
Again I want to be clear
there are not studies
that show that these drugs
specifically work in ASD
but we have no reason to
believe that they don't.
What about anxiety disorders?
Kids with ASD also get anxious.
I think there's pretty
good evidence that suggests
that using benzodiazepines
and related drugs for anything
more than a few doses is
probably not a good idea
in these--for these kids.
Probably not a good idea for anybody.
But that's another story.
A significant number of
individuals who get benzodiazepines
have dyscontrol syndromes.
It's sort of like alcohol.
And so we have a tendency
for those kids who are
quite anxious to use again the SSRIs.
But there, because they work
in treating anxiety disorders
in other children, in
other people with anxiety,
not because it's unique to ASD.
Now there are a bunch of
new medications around
and Dr. Sher referred to them.
And they've seen varying
degrees of success.
Most of the trials are quite small.
There's a large trial now going on
of vasopressin 1A antogonist.
It's a Rauch funded study
and there are a number
of other companies
getting ready to come out
and the basic idea is that these drugs
improve social responsiveness.
They do in rodents.
It's not quite clear that
they do in human beings
and the preliminary data
has been quite uneven.
Now partly due to very small sample sizes
and not very well done
studies, but this is something
to be watching.
And I think that there's
lots of new drugs coming out
that are targeting the evolving
biology of the disorder
and I think you're gonna start
seeing people trying things.
I would just urge you to be cautious,
because--wait until the trials are done.
Because these kids have enough trouble.
If we give them a drug that
turns out to be a bad idea
and then it causes damage,
it's the least thing
we need to do.
There's an evolving interest
in cognitive enhancers,
the drugs that we use to treat dementia,
Alzheimer's disease, and
these look like they may have
some positive effects,
particularly for individuals
with intellectual disability,
but I think the effect
sizes are very small.
The side effects are
large and so it's a really
a careful clinical decision
that has to be made.
But I'd watch this literature
because I think it's gonna
evolve over the next several years.
And then there are a
whole variety of other
complementary and alternative treatments.
And I'm not going to go through these now
because you're going to get
one of the world's experts
to talk about that in Bob
Hendren in a little bit.
Bob knows more about
this than anybody I know.
And I think there's some
evidence that there's
some real potential for
helping people with ASD
but the sample sizes are
small and so it's hard to know
for sure what's really working.
And then there are a
gazillions of other treatments
that people proposed and
I think our population,
we need to be very cautious
about using these treatments
until they're well-established.
I'm gonna give you an example.
This is a drug called secretin.
It is a drug that--it's a
GI hormone that was touted
as a cure for autism and
as it turns out when you do
a proper trial the difference
between the placebo
and the active drug was indistinguishable.
In fact, the placebo may have
been a little bit better.
But more importantly had
the potential for causing
really serious adverse events.
People could get--develop
a tolerance to this
or an immunologic reaction
to it because it came
from pigs and it wasn't
exactly the same as human
and then it would disrupt
their ability to digest.
So we have to be careful.
By the way, this is a drug
that costs $75 a vial to buy
but people bought it
up and were selling it
for $3,000 a vial and people
were mortgaging their homes
and putting kids on this.
It was just an awful thing.
Wait for the trials to
be done because they're--
really, one has to be careful about this.
Another popular treatment
is chelation where we need
to get all the heavy
metals out of the body.
We don't because you
need the heavy metals.
If you don't have them, you die.
And in fact, some of the
chelation--kids who have been
chelated have died.
So there are lots of proposed
treatments that you can give
that may seem to make sense,
but until you see a trial
you don't really want to do it.
So there are three caveats I
want to give to you as I close.
Number one, these are
individual patients in a study.
And you can see some people
get better, some people
get worse, and some people stay the same.
So when we tell you that
a study shows something,
you need to remember that
not everybody in that study
got better.
So because we tell you that
SSRIs may work for stereotopies,
when you go to give it to a
patient, some of your patients
won't get better.
It's not because the study
was bad or there's something
wrong with your patient,
it's just not everybody
gets better.
Secondly, all medications
have side effects, and this is
particularly problematic
in ASD because our patients
often have difficultly telling
us about their side effects.
So we have to make sure we query them.
We need to make sure their
caregivers understand them.
And we need to be very
careful that they not be made
uncomfortable by the medications
that we're giving them.
And finally, just because a
small amount of medication
works well, doesn't mean
a lot will work better.
In fact, in most cases,
reducing the dose will probably
lead to a better outcome
than other things as well.
So be cautious.
And the bottom line is that
we want to use treatments
that work, and some of the
treatments that work are really
environmental treatments.
And we need to help the speech
and language pathologist,
the behavioral therapist do
a better job by supplementing
those--management of those
behaviors with the medications.
At the end of the day, we
want the kids to get better,
and we should do everything
we can, bring all the tools
together to get them better.
And at that point, I'll stop.
Thank you very much.